la pêche encore et toujours sujet de
discorde dans le dossier du breakbeat
alors que tout semblait entériné avec
l'accord commercial de sortie
définitivement validé par bruxelles la
semaine dernière des points
d'achoppement continue d'attiser les
tensions
au coeur du conflit les îles
anglo-normandes zone dont l'accès serait
plus contraignant pour les pêcheurs
français on considère que si de
nouvelles exigences pour les zonages de
mer où les engins de pêche sont intégrés
dans les licences alors même qu'elles
n'ont pas été notifiés à la commission
européenne
elles sont nulles et non avenues si le
royaume uni veut introduire de nouvelles
dispositions
il doit les notifier à la commission
européenne qui nous les notifie ce qui
nous permet d'engager un dialogue
ensuite à ce stade on a découvert ces
nouvelles mesures techniques qui ne sont
pas applicable en l'état à nos pêcheurs
les pêcheurs comptent justement sur
l'état pour envoyer une réponse ferme
aux britanniques
il est évident qu'il va y avoir des
réponses à l'agression dont nous sommes
victimes par les autorités de jersey par
rapport aux autorisations de pêche
on espère que l'état prendra des mesures
de représailles le message est
apparemment passé puisque devant
l'assemblée nationale la ministre
française de la mère annick girardin a
mis les choses au point
vous le savez dans l'accord il ya des
mesures de rétorsion eh bien ces mesures
de rétention nous sommes prêts à les
utiliser lors ap la france a des moyens
s'est inscrit dans l'accord nous avons
des moyens et même si je regrette si on
ne devait en iard est arrivé et bien on
y sera s'il faut le faire
pour l'heure seule une quarantaine de
navires français équipés d'un système
permettant leur localisation en mer sont
autorisés à pêcher dans les eaux du new
jersey